[Music]
hello and welcome to GameSpot after dark
episode 38 GameSpot's official video
game podcast
I'm your host Jake Decker and joining me
this week is Kelly plaguey hello
jean-luc psyche hi
and two more Hussien let me outside let
him outside
well I mean other than being trapped how
y'all doing yeah that's really hot I
believe the term is broadly fine the sun
is shining mm-hmm that's true it is it
is nice outside can't go too far outside
but I know what video game sales are up
we are experts in the field that is most
sought after right now
video games are good well life is I can
tell you got a pop filter because that
would have hit really hard so they say I
was explaining this to everyone in our
area there's a it's like a a couple a
bandit couple that is stealing Amazon
packages from various apartments and
they got us good and they stole my pop
filter so I've had to reorder a new one
in the meantime I've just stuck three of
my socks on my hope they're clean socks
oh they're very clean yeah yeah I've
designated these as pop filter socks now
so I don't wear them okay wait so you
have three socks though what are you
doing with that extra so I say I have I
have a washing machine that is I'm
pretty sure is sentient and he's eating
like one sock per wash cycle because
every time I do it I I come out and I'm
like there's one sock missing always so
this is one of the rogue socks or three
of the rogue socks yeah three of them
that's a good way to put those forlorn
orphan socks
yeah I'm giving them a new purpose
mm-hmm and then you'll just have to get
rid of them I guess once well you can
pair two of them up and get rid of one
once get your actual
filter never or are you puppets yeah you
could mix up puppets I'll just frame it
and like hurry up I was like Cove it pop
filler like memorial well anyway
tomorrow do you want to kick it off what
have you been playing this week or
watching so I am on a intense comedown
from final fantasy 7 review and by calm
down I mean like I'm still playing it
but it's it kind of is a bit drug issue
where I'm like I should stop this but I
still need a hit of it so I keep going
back to do
I saw I've completed a second time I had
a I had a safe that was like midway
through the game that I picked up and
went from there again and now I was
doing bits and pieces just to kind of
wrap up any essential stuff there's a
few extra bosses that you can fight and
that kind of stuff so I'm kind of
weaning myself off of Final Fantasy 7
and as much as possible other than that
I returned to doom eternal ice there's
something about that game that's just
isn't clicking with me I really I'm
playing on xbox one so already I'm like
on the back foot because I don't feel
super comfortable playing that game with
a controller however I do have the elite
what it was it was newly called like
elite pros it elite pro - yeah something
I've got that and that's helping and
that's helping but I think if he schemes
it's like a very definition of all those
days it's welcome in every regard like
to me like it doesn't feel short and
sharp exciting like the first reboot did
in terms of its skirmishes the missions
go on for far too long and there's a lot
of what feels like padding in it but
when the combat happens I'm so into it
and then I realize it's just I'm gonna
have to do this other stuff that I don't
really care about I don't mind the
platforming but just like I just wanna
shoot things and then like the missions
seem to go on for like an hour at a time
and then the stuff in between or it's
like come back to your ship and
customize unlike
feel like you guys missed the point here
this should be like this was like John
wick in its execution the first time
like every scene is short shop like has
a punch and they've turned it into like
some really arduous it feels like the
matrix now it's like trying to over
explain everything and it's forgotten
that it was just about shooting guns and
dodging like it's just every time I play
I'm like I'll do a couple of skirmishes
I'm just like I don't wanna sit for
another half an hour in this one mission
account I'm done it's like I'm forcing
myself to go back to it I do it's one go
on it it's weird because what you're
describing is what I was worried that
what would happen with doom eternal
least for me but when I actually played
it I thought that each of the missions
were like really interesting I had a lot
of fun learning all the weapons that for
me I like doom eternal a lot more than
the original because I feel like there
is far less padding yeah not that there
was a lot of padding in the original
doom I will say the stuff in your ship
like I didn't do any of that I
immediately just started at a new
mission but I think another reason that
I enjoyed it too is that I like only
played one level a day so I never really
liked od'd on anything maybe that's a
good way to approach it because I do
like the other thing is like I'm these
days are more aware of time then and I
hate that I'm doing that and I'm sure
it's the same for you guys like I can't
switch off the internal clock in my in
my gaming sessions anymore like I used
to be able to say in front of a you know
in front of the game and just be like
it's gonna start playing and then I'll
look at the time was like well seven
hours have gone by these days I'm like I
can feel every minute pass and I'm aware
of it and I'm constantly like is this
the best use of my time currently like
in terms of game playing like am I
having fun right now
though like you should be like a grind
in an RPG for hours and hours and on end
and for some games I do that but I think
there's something about the way doing
place that is just like I can feel my
internal clock ticking and I'm
constantly thinking could I be playing
something else that is more consistently
and immediately more rewarding to me but
I think I'll carry on
it just because I feel like I haven't
also given enough time to get into a
groove and like watch it I'm like maybe
three or four missions in okay not that
far but I do like the compa and I like a
lot of like the kind of skirmishes they
set up and the thinking that you have to
do in the actual like movement and
switching weapons and collecting em all
that kind of stuff
yes I'll probably stick with that and
then beyond that I've been rewatching
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood because
why not good good enemy just one of
Jake's favorite I have I was waiting for
someone to respond with Full Metal
Alchemist Full Metal Alchemist
metal ominous yeah so I've been watching
that just because it's amazing and I
have like I over the years I watched an
episode or a scene here or there but
I've just been a while since I've done a
full rewatch so I'm doing that now and
then I watched the movie yesterday with
my roommate called confessions so like
we take it week or week by week like
I'll pick a movie she'll pick a moon
pick a movie and then we watch it and
this week one was my pick confessions
have you ever heard of this so it's just
Japanese movie which is a rollercoaster
ride every time I show it to someone
their immediate first words are what the
[ __ ] does is this the movie that has a
song by Thom Yorke in it blasts flowers
yes okay okay because I remember they're
the reason I know this is because it was
years ago when you showed it to Lucy and
she posted on her Instagram that she was
listening to that song a lot yeah and I
was like I was like I love that song and
no one knows about that song because
it's a rare Radiohead b-side and she was
like oh yeah it's in this movie tomorrow
showed us yep that's the movie that's
the only film York song I know so from
New York yeah and like it's also got
like the start of an XX song so it's
like almost samples one of the XX songs
in it but the movie is basically about
this teacher who has a young child
she brings the child to school one day
and the child is killed and she figures
out that students in her class are
responsible for it so and they they're
like they don't understand that and the
core can see is the Japanese penal code
basically forgives - for literally any
crime so if you're in Japan I believe
it's still the case you can commit
murder as long as you're underneath a
certain age you won't be prosecuted for
it and she is like I've lost my child
and she still wants revenge and so what
she does is this is gonna sound real
weird and real extreme but it works
within the movie she's she infects two
of those kids they at the start of the
each class they give like juice boxes
milk boxes to each kid just to like as a
part of health thing she infects two of
them with HIV and has the kids drinking
and then says two of those who of those
were infected you know who you are now
you get to learn the value of life and
it's just about these kids the mental
state of these kids unraveling and it is
a trip it is it's like it is it is one
of the best movies I've ever seen I love
it and easie is a mindfuck of a movie
but it's also got like a message to it
and it's like kind of the cruelty of
children how screwed up the Japanese
penal code system is the value of life
and also it's like a revenge movie in
the in the way like you know there's
it's it's not uplifting but you feel
kind of on her side because you're like
yeah these kids are [ __ ] I hate them
all it's got like Death Note vibes to it
it's got like monster wipes to it it's
it's one of my favorite films of all
time and like
my roommate chest you you may know from
games what universe is had the same
reaction that Lucy and the GameSpot UK
team had when I showed them and they's
that was they went what the [ __ ]
and then were like that was insane that
was amazing
but yeah I believe it's called um
confessions in Europe and us western
territories and in Japan it might be
called like confessions of Moriguchi or
mortgagees confessions because it's just
that's a teacher's name but highly
recommend it very difficult to find that
these days sadly there's not streaming
anywhere but if you can figure out a way
of getting it i encourage you to watch
it it's it's what it's a very unique
film and it them from the moment it
starts you're gripped first time I
watched it I watched it and then I felt
like I hadn't like no time has passed
and I immediately watched it again and
it's that kind of film that's like
really it's the definition of like
gripping from the outset tomorrow you
should do a viewing party on the
gamespot discord I mean I would be well
up for it you also don't like sweets on
Fridays telly about you what have you
been up to well speaking of death no
actually my brother and I made my mom
watch Death Note with us so my mom's not
totally new to anime my mom actually was
the one who like got me to watch the
Pokemon anime for example but she's also
seeing a couple shows including food
wars which is like probably on the upper
end of like extreme capital a anime so
she's like prepared but my brother's
really into Death Note and I'd actually
never seen the anime I've only read the
manga so we did like a Death Note watch
it was just on Netflix and it was fun
for me because I you know like I'm
familiar with the Death Note music but
hearing it in context was really cool
just scenes I'm familiar with the music
is really like creepy and weird and also
especially like towards the end of the
show
the we you hearing people's voices that
certain events transpire is really
powerful the animation is it great
though
I would say like the animation is not
great mid-2000s whatever but it was fun
my mom hates me so so much
yeah I already like me so I like to
there's actually a character in
confessions who reminds me exactly of
Misa and like she's not rollerskating or
blonde but like it's basically the same
character and like there's also a
character in the movie that's basically
like yeah yeah you know light that's fun
and I actually told her brother but the
next thing we should watch which he
hasn't seen is Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood so I think we're gonna do
that next but I was also contain I was
trying to like recommend shows that
maybe he would like to watch after Death
Note
because he's he's only watched a couple
of anime like death no he likes one
punch man so it's like what if we
watched like Psychopaths or or even like
death parade which I really really like
that's that's pretty is great so that's
what I'm up to I'm still playing Anna
lacrosse and obviously yeah I think like
time I definitely feel time differently
right now Animal Crossing really grounds
me and like the day's passing it makes
days feel like segmented whereas they
could really blend together right now
and I am trying to spend more time
outside like in the yard my parents have
a have a yard which I never had growing
up and I don't have in bay area so I'm
just kind of taking advantage um having
the thing I always dreamed of having as
a child I guess because we can't really
walk the dogs right now because they see
one that can the healthy one broke his
leash so I'm just I just sit outside now
and watches people go by and I'm like
wow you guys are really like outside huh
no I just want to give a shout out to
Isabel for letting us know what day it
is everything love that I also watched
the follower
thing for Tiger King which was kind of
there was a weird Joel McHale hosts like
interviews with people who were in Tiger
- is it the Netflix one that they added
yeah okay every every media site has
been like everyone is trying to get
people from tiger King on their podcast
on their night show whatever it is
whenever I scroll through YouTube all my
recommend its are like this character
who showed up in one episode for 10
minutes is now on this and you can hear
the untold the real untold story of
tiger king and it's just like alright
Netflix hit and now you guys are trying
to you guys are trying to copy the
success if we could have one character
or person from tiger King on this
podcast who would it be
I respect that I think South would fit
in yeah which one staff again that is
the one who got his arm ripped off okay
okay I just turned up for work the next
day yeah anyway John Luke what have you
been up to I've been a hard on that JRPG
train post final fantasy I feel like I
have like a like a group chat with Ben
Janka and and Michael Hyman mass but I
only and we are all just like
simultaneously playing like seven
different JRPGs at once right now it's
like Big Ben's playing like Final
Fantasy Crisis Core Michael's playing
like Final Fantasy 13 spring from
Fantasy thirteen Crisis Core and 7
remake at the same time yeah and soccer
yeah yes Batman is that man is playing
literally like seven games that where is
he finding all these like micro between
what hours that we know exists no idea
doesn't sleep so I'm not going that hard
but I have made like a list now because
I think like eventually I'm playing I'm
replaying Final Fantasy with my
girlfriends and having a great time like
like you I I didn't think I'd I figured
out baby be like a little bored
playing in a second time like totally
not it's so good like I'm more than
happy to play it again I think I'm gonna
play the original after that just
because of like I want that in that
context you know I feel like now's the
right time to do it
you should play I I would also like to
play a is a is like I feel like I'm
pretty good at pegging did not help I
feel like I'm pretty good at identifying
what Final Fantasies people would like I
think you would like a quite a bit
because of how we're is and you and Ben
especially I beg you I have been playing
Final Fantasy 7 I stopped the the the
original one I stopped when I made it
out of Midgar but I saw that took around
five or six hours or so but I was really
enjoying that and then I stopped because
I'm trying to decide if I want to wait
for Final Fantasy 7 - and do that before
I continue Final Fantasy 7 original
we'll see but I took a but I took a
break from that and I actually started
playing Chrono Trigger which I don't
have for the first time like three hours
in or so I'm not super far but still
what do you think of it so far I'm
really enjoying it the the the one thing
that's driving me crazy is that the
directional inputs in battle don't
always work where I want to go like all
like want to attack a character to the
left and it'll go down or something like
that and it'll all aim at the wrong
character I think part of it is because
I'm playing with a control stick like I
mean it just it it's not as good as if I
was using a d-pad which I should switch
to but my brain is always hard to do
that but so far I'm really enjoying it I
feel like I haven't played enough of it
but I thought the court scene was really
clever
I think that was the moment where I was
like okay I see why people were
checking out about this game oh just you
wait oh man tease of what it's gonna
happen
yeah I'm excited oh how cool is that
intro sequence though the intro sequence
really is pretty good yeah if you like
that you should watch Dragon Ball Z
Dragon Ball Z yeah and the music is so
good as well like I love that game so
much which-which
sorry I'm you might have said which
platform you're playing it on PC steam
which I hear is not great but apparently
they've patched it to make it better I
wish I could play NDS cuz I got it on TS
but I don't have my BS with me or the
game I was gonna ask you guys know which
translation is on the PC version is that
the original or is it the yes
translation I think it's the original
yeah alright I think well I think they
it is well like they might have been
changed since it came out cuz I remember
I came on people are like what I'm a
weird purist we're because they
retranslated it for the DS version it's
technically a better translation but I
love the original snazz translation
because like fraud talks in like Old
English yeah and like there's just it's
something really charming about it that
like even though the DSS ones like
technically better I'm just like nah I
want I want that og translation in fact
one time I went to a conference in
college about I went to like a talk
about localization for Japanese games
and like queer history just bear with me
for a second it was about how Chrono
Trigger I I mean the character's name is
spelled fleet I don't know if anybody's
pronouncing it differently right but
that character in the original Japanese
is like a very effeminate man I think or
there's like a there's a problematic
trans thing going on but it was so hard
to translate into English because of the
way Japanese has like feminine sentence
markers like there's there's certain
ways to speak that just you can't
translate really and so that complicated
howls that characters gender was
presented in the localization so I'm
curious if that's different in the DES
translation versus the original
translation I haven't planted chrono
trigger but I just thought that was
interesting linguistically because
there's difficult thing she can't look
lies so when Johnson Tom like when you
brought up these different translations
that's what made me think of it like oh
I wonder if the translations were about
like localizing it just adds a better
better translation or modernizing it as
well are you uh Kelly are you familiar
with legends of localization yes they're
a fantastic resource for like cool
little tidbits like that like talking
about subtle changes in like translation
and they they go all in the guy NATO I
think is how you say their name they're
famous for doing like the fan
translation of mother3 I believe yeah
yeah like there if you're someone who
like finds that fascinating like the
differences between localization and
like changes I highly recommend checking
out their website where they just like
post a ton of stuff and they've done
like full like books they've published
on like Zelda and stuff like that so
yeah I just find it so interesting also
did you know that an animal crossing
Sahara and Gracie Grace our original
email and the original Japanese Wow
oh you know I was thinking about the
other day County this is very specific
to me and Kalia / this isolation thing
happened as month or the month of us we
were supposed to re-enroll in Japanese
classes about enrolling in Japanese
classes at the school in San Francisco
forever and we were gonna do it in the
fall but we were like that's that's like
big game season we won't be able to go
to class or study so we were like okay
spring it's our time yeah
all right well let's keep moving along
here I'm like what else have you been
[Applause]
uh so yeah I've been playing JRPGs I got
back in the Final Fantasy 14 a little
bit very slowly trucking along in that
and I finally got to like a different
area I'm still in that that realm were
born stuff so it's it's it's getting
better but it's still fairly dry but I'm
I feel more motivated to get through it
now because I've like in feeling this
like passion for Final Fantasy now
because of a 7 remake otherwise I've
been playing persona 5 royal which I
don't really have anything else to say
because I feel like we keep talking
about it every week other than like it's
organically it's so good you know it was
me and Georgia when we started it we
were thinking like we were kind of
nervous that we would be sort of a
little bored of it because we're like uh
you know we played the other one and
it's gonna is gonna be kind of repeating
a lot of elements nah man that game
still hits that game still hits real
hard when it's when it's on point
especially the the first I think the
first arc of that game is unfortunately
probably the best arc in my opinion like
I'd the comma sheet of stuff is it's
really messed up and really like hard to
get through but I also think it's like
so well done and feel so personal in a
way that the rest of the game never
quite hits again kind of intentionally
like it's the whole point of that game
is like the the targets that the fan of
these are hitting like escalate over
time and and that's kind of the point of
it but because of that like when it
doesn't feel as personal or like as you
don't feel quite that like level of like
hatred for like the the CEO of a burger
joint the way you do for like your
school's gym teacher who is abusing his
students there's something I mean the
normal average hatred it's like it's
like you can hate Jeff Bezos but if you
knew there was like someone in your
building that was like abusing your
friends you'd be a different kind of
yeah or clean your packages oh yeah yeah
I think that game just really comes out
of the gate swinging it's so strong and
and not to like diminish the rest of the
game like it's still so good but like
yeah whoa I'm gonna create a persona 5
clone that's for like local crimes like
stealing packages gotta go inside the
palace and change there on it oh my god
absolutely holy crap yes I'm playing
like all my neighbor who's Bill who
builds furniture at 1:00 a.m. in the
morning listen changes heart the guy in
the microwave in the office in the
office gotta go change their heart other
than that I've been playing I've been
replaying Resident Evil 4 for a feature
I'm working on which is sort of like
related to the remake kind of like what
what we'd like to how would like a
remake to do so I'm just replaying that
that game still super good Beckham holds
it up incredibly well I took I don't
know what I have to say about Resident
Evil 4 this billion times on the
Internet are they then
it's Resident Evil 4 and I still think
that game has some like the the
cheesiest dialog like every line in that
game I remember so well not just like
the shopkeeper but like all of Leon's
stupid one-liners the like there's this
apart when you meet Salazar who's the
like the dude who like owns the castle
he's like the like Napoleon looking
character and he says something to the
effect of like oh like I'm you know I'm
here too like he basically gives like a
villian speech and then Leon just goes
no way bro I forgot just like how much
of that game is just like Leon
channeling like this weird dorky like
he's like a dorky Solid Snake it's like
what they're going for in that game it's
just so good and I
the one thing like if they're gonna do a
remake of that game they need to keep
that like you need to keep that just
like can't be almost a grind house type
of energy that that game has it's so
good it's like it's like if this was a
movie he'd be played by Mark Wahlberg
just because of how like he can do
secret agent ball so can is mostly a
goof an idiot yeah yeah that's a good
pic like yeah is the song B's where the
zombies at bingo
uh yeah that game is great and that's
about it I don't have anything else we
all hold on sorry you've got Guitar Hero
on hand probably no one's talked about
in years and you talk about all these
other games that weren't on here but you
haven't talked about guitar here at
least like one sentence okay so oh
Georgia has been my girlfriend who's
been itching to play guitar hero she
like grew up playing as a kid like
played it all on experts she's been
itching to get back into it before
everything went down when I went to pax
it if you've ever been to a pax they
like local like retro game shop so like
have booths there that you can go and
like buy retro games from and I saw they
had Guitar Hero so I picked up a couple
of Guitar Hero games for her and then
she ordered a guitar which just arrived
last Sunday so she has been playing
through all of the Guitar Hero games I
actually haven't been playing myself
I've just been watching her play an
expert and being like wow you're so good
at this which is great because like
really oh wow
you played green grass and high tides on
expert for me that baby who just keeps
seeing George Washington stands up is
she's like George what are you doing my
shower but yeah it's been really it's
actually just been a ton of fun like
watching her play like listening is some
old like classic rock it makes me
really want to play rock band again you
made a face I feel like I feel like I
have and I know nothing but no I I used
to have rock band and I got rid of it a
while ago I mean it that was way back in
Vermont I wouldn't have it here anyway
but a man it really makes me want to
like go to Ebay or something and order
like a rock band drumset and play it in
this you gotta do something if I'm gonna
be stuck in here might as well learn how
to master every song in rock band on
expert explains mm-hmm yeah we'll get to
that yeah we're not worried we're about
done with two and we're gonna move on to
three I thought two had the best track
list but it's actually three I think 300
breeze got some some bangers I differ
looking and I remember always just
waiting for like a Led Zeppelin rock
band but it never happened cuz Led Zep
now we're not gonna a lot to you not
music I can name like three movies I've
ever had well the weird thing I never
played rock band one or not a rock band
one a Qatar one I it makes sense now but
I didn't know about it most of those
songs are covers in the national game
because like cuz uh there is one in
particular that um like it started
playing and I was like this sounds just
slightly off like the vocalist you sound
not quite right
cuz I'm are that being a big thing with
like rock band I think they were like
most of the tracks for master you say
something like that but anyway that's
cool it's yeah that's what happens when
you're isolated you break out the
plastic guitars again yeah I wish I had
my teacher hero deck and I wish DJ hero
who what game hundred well I've been
playing more fallout 76 I don't know
what else to say about it like I'm
having fun with it but it's the
wastelanders update doesn't add as much
as that well it adds a good amount of
just doesn't really change things as
much as I hoped it is still lots of bugs
it
it is fun exploring that world I have a
video that should be out before the end
of the week that you can check out if
you want to if you're curious about
maybe jumping back in that video is
probably a good place to start
but yeah I don't know that was it's kind
of been what I've been spending most of
my time on and hasn't been okay it
hasn't been I haven't had a bad time
like I've been having fun but it also
kind of like what tomorrow was saying
about like should I really be spending
my time doing this like is there
something else I could be doing other
than this and I guess the answer is no
cuz I was making a video but at the same
time it was like yeah there's so many
other things I'd rather be playing right
now that being said I did enjoy my time
with it but the other thing that I
haven't playing here and there which I
cannot talk a lot about due to embargo
restrictions but I can say that I've
been playing it which is gears tactics
the review should be up early next week
not by me by someone else but I've been
playing a good amount and all I'll say
is that I am surprised by how much I'm
enjoying it
because I got to be Vega than that but
yeah I think I think people who well I
guess there's a new ex-con XCOM game
coming out soon yeah I love that they
were like yeah release the ex-con like I
do is a little more straightforward it's
still really hard but yeah like I said I
don't say too much but I think people
who enjoy gears will probably enjoy who
enjoyed gears and tactical games will
probably really enjoy this game funds of
the genre fans of the genre yeah you do
and like a edit of the ex-con Camaro
squad art but with Nina oh my lord
I'm confused
Oh metal alchemists yeah there's been
too much anime in this episode too much
anime let's talk about some points fun
I think everyone like rightly goes to
the Nina thing but the the the chimera
the bird chimera earlier in the season
that is as [ __ ] up the one that's like
was it was a name wrote Rosa Rosa where
they transmute yeah there's a in
personally her boyfriend or whatever
yeah yeah yeah that one is like as anime
alright let's get into the news this
week there's not a whole lot but we're
gonna start with two big new updates
that came out Mario maker is out today
Wednesday and Animal Crossing will be
out tomorrow Thursday so if you're
listening this on Friday both are out
you can mess around with them both but
the Mario maker one seems pretty cool
you can now create worlds and then place
your levels in those worlds and people
can go through them honestly haven't
played much mario maker since it came
out but what i think we're all pretty
excited for here is the animal crossing
update cali did you want to break down
what's new in that and what we can
expect sure so the trailer for the April
update detailed a number of new features
and events so the first one is nature
day which was hinted at before and
that's related to leaf coming to the
game so wow I should really back up
though so there's two new visitors leave
the gardening sloth and then jolly red
formerly crazy red who is selling art
once again with jolly red coming that
will unlock a new wing to the museum so
there's a museum upgrade and then
there's also nature day which is related
to leaf where there's like special Nick
miles events and other things tied to
the earth leaf also brings with him
shrubs a much requested feature as
people are pretty excited about that
so that's like the immediate stuff
that's happening and then there's made a
starting on May 1st which there was a
hint of Rover actually coming back to
the game and then there's international
museum day which has this very Japanese
like stamp collecting thing where you go
through the museum it gets stamps and
you get
warts and then there's wedding season
which I love because boom and you get to
go top Harv's island and set up
photoshoots for recent irises
anniversary so the takeaway from all of
that one takeaway from all of that is
that a number of returning characters
have been confirmed so me Red Rover is
like soft confirmed but you definitely
see him and then recent cyrus where they
don't have retail their old furniture
refurbishing flea market kind of
building but they are in the game and
that was one thing I was like me really
cool if recent Cyrus could like edit the
colors a furniture that you couldn't
customize yourself like how we're all
like please trade me for the cotton
candy stall that isn't this color
because it's not in my game but so I'm
like okay T a recent Cyrus potential but
that's events basically that covers
through June so that's a lot of upcoming
events that were revealed and new
features and the art he still sells
forgeries so you have to check out
whether they're real or not and he shows
up on your secret beach so there's
actually a purpose of beach we're just
cool I'm excited i I mean I think we all
kind of knew that they'd be adding a lot
of these characters back in as time
progresses in with updates but to
actually see them was really oh no what
keeps happening well off cam I'll
continue anyway but to actually see red
back there and the sea leaf and to even
see Rover back in the corner was really
exciting which I'm so excited to see
what Rover does too because Rover always
has such an instrumental role in
previous Animal Crossing games and
getting you set up or just helping out
with certain things so it was weird not
to seem right away but now that he's in
it I'm curious what he's gonna do I'm
still holding out for Brewster though
Brewster and and the coffee shop or what
I want the most
I bet because there's it seems like
they're they're reticent to add new
buildings from what you already have so
I feel like you've run out of space
pretty quickly
if there was a cafe it would return to
being inside the museum like it wasn't
yeah so according to the data mines
that's what that's what is being alluded
to like there'll be two upgrades to the
museum one is for the art thing and then
one is for read there they are daily
they are data mined so I mean what is
for Easter oh yeah one is for Bruce
their data they are data mines they may
not be true but like but a lot of it has
been true based on this recent trailer
so the stuff that is confirmed is that
one museum upgrade so we don't know
what's after that but the interesting
thing about Rover and him being in the
made a section of that trailer is that
in Pocket Camp
so in like other animal like main animal
crossing games Rover or like was the one
who asked you your name and the name of
the town you were going to and did that
like kind of intake questioning on the
train or whatever transport in wild
world he actually wasn't doing that
captain was doing that but after that he
did but um in Pocket Camp Rover was more
of a merchant and he hosted the I think
it's Gardens Safari events where you
catch seasonal bugs that aren't in
normal Animal Crossing games so
therefore mobile and plant specific
seasonal flowers that don't exist
normally and Animal Crossing games and
you get Rover furniture so there's a
there's potential for him to be more of
a like actually roving and like doing
doing things in your game as like an
event related and it's in an event
related capacity so May Day was kind of
vague it was basically like you go on a
special made a tour to an island that's
not like the other deserted islands and
there it was like a hedge maze and there
were items in the hedge maze and then
Rovers in the corner so I'm interested
to see if like rover like dishes out the
prizes or is somewhere this otherwise
related in some way so but I'm excited
because like that's a lot of stuff
planned over a lot of new features
rolling out and like it was just events
for June like who's to say there's not
through June so who's to say there's not
more new features or other updates
coming in the interim I'm just really
excited yeah me too
next sir we have here is Xbox Series X
logo trademark so more do you want to
talk about this because I imagine you're
the one who added it yeah I added it not
much to say about it other than it's
there like they they trademarked an
actual logo and it has like a series X
on it instead of just the standard Xbox
logo it's kind of like an off-brand
sports apparel thing but whatever I mean
that's pretty much it if you want to see
what the potential so they sometimes
it's like trademark a buncha logos just
in case so this might not I look at it
I'm like some people are into it I'm
like cool but Timmy looks very in
elegant it looks quite like like I said
like a sports for anything or even a am
like a deodorant almost yeah so like I I
do wonder if this is one of like many
that they they're like trademarking just
in case if it does end up being this you
can do better than that Microsoft but
whatever that's pretty much it
all right well those are all the news
stories we plan to talk about on this
video so we're gonna move over to
listener questions and if you've got
questions you can email us email us at
after dark podcast at gamespot.com or
you can join our discord if you'd like
to do that please send I you can either
email us or you can send myself jean-luc
pretty much any of us at DM on Twitter
and we'll get you in there as soon as we
can
but it's a good community so far and a
lot of people have been asking some
really good questions do you want to
take this first one Kali sure this is
this from Triceratops I it's in the
wrong section this is from Triceratops
on discord what is the best opening
gameplay of a game mine would have to be
Zelda paratha profiles except eggs so
exiting not exciting exiting that cave
to see the landscape ready to be
explored gave me goosebumps they're
literally talking about this earlier
back we were and I had picked this
question before and then I was like oh I
wonder if seen and pulled that from
the the GameSpot discord but I didn't
see any reference to it was it kind of
interesting I think it was a coincidence
which is really weird we were having
this conversation in GameSpot slack
today I don't know this is a hard one
for me okay I was just gonna say what I
said in slack which is mass spec - this
is like the one that always stands out
to me yeah that that just that intro the
Normandie getting destroyed it's so like
Oh cuz you just you're watching all the
people that you like built that
relationship with over like that course
of that first game and it's not so good
it like it really just gets you like
invested immediately out of the game
I was gonna say oblivion I think that's
like the first game I can think of that
does that thing where it's like you
start in this very narrow passageway and
then you open the door and you open the
exit and then there's just this like
breath wow there's just this big world
in front of you and you're just the
possibilities seem endless and there's
so many games that have copied that like
I mean not copied it but like so many
games do that as well now and it's I
just remember being so impressed when I
first saw that I thought you were gonna
say that game's intro like the intro
video that plays we're Patrick Stewart
slow I do like the intro no shut the
jaws of oblivion and then the music
starts wailing you're like yeah does
that fly over of the Imperial City too
which is really cool that's playing the
music yeah that intro is really good too
I've said it before but I think this or
either has one of the best intro
sequences in terms of setting up a story
visuals and that kind of stuff but it's
not playable in terms of playability I
think now we're solid to stanker
sequence is pretty fantastic I think
that contained sequence the whole tanker
is one of the best stealth games in
itself of all time I just love it so
much and I remember getting a demo of it
before the game come came out and I must
have put 150 hours into that demo easily
and it is it was so good it was watching
Ben genka play that demo he shows do you
like all that cuz he's play he's done
the same thing where he said he played
it like a billion times he'll go in and
he'll be like I'm gonna show you
all the little tricks and like
techniques and things you can do and it
blows my mind how much the little
details they put in the biggest
crowd-pleaser
when you're showing someone off that
section is towards the end where there's
like a series of rooms that is just
filled with enemies enemy soldiers
listening to everything that's over
being projected on all but it's like
sixty enemies per room all lined up and
if you know exactly how to you can
basically creep up behind very specific
enemies and hold them up and then make
them give you an item and then knock
them out without anyone else in the room
seeing you and you just do that and when
you do that you're like oh my god always
happening this is wild because you're
just surrounded by enemies nothing I
guess like on the topic of stealth games
to the lighthouse mission the first
mission in chaos theory I was super
impressed by when I first played because
I think there was such a huge jump
between Pandora tomorrow on chaos theory
in terms of graphics and gameplay and
all that stuff and when you get there
and there's like this thunderstorm and
rains pouring down and you're on the
beaches Sam Fisher and it's just like oh
man this is this is I mean I'm in for a
game for a ride I would say my brain
doesn't really remember these kinds of
things so that my favorite opening
sequences or when I get to assign stat
points to my character so I played the
intro to like I played the beginning of
kotor so many times because I just liked
[ __ ] like character basically that's
really boring answer but that's my
answer
oh you know I like doing that too mmm
stalk cells and bone and always have
that as well I also really liked
controls opening I think it's like
really cinematic yeah controls are good
all right next question here from Dede
also from discord can we pretend to e3
is going to happen this year what are
your predictions by conferences
Microsoft Warner Bros Ubisoft Nintendo
and square was Warner Bros supposed to
have one supposedly wasn't that like a
thing or
no I figure it could take a while for
all of us to go through our predictions
on each of them so maybe I'll just
we'll start with Microsoft Callie do you
want to do you want to do Microsoft
predictions this is so hard for me
because I just can't even I have a hard
time pretending but I guess Hey
I mean yeah that would be there that's
bound to be the halo series X series X
stuff fable fable fables on I'd hitch my
wagon to that will show up this year if
Microsoft
I mean Microsoft is presumably gonna
have some sort of event around e3 I
imagine we'll see a new fable Forza if I
guess yeah that turn 10 could do for so
if playground is as room at making fable
you know those simulation favors the
fable so forces are not my cup of tea
yeah I'd be more excited for fable I
think we'll probably get to see a little
more of senua sacrifice right oh yeah
and then whatever that new game obsidian
is working on that isn't the Grand Trunk
the kids no no there's another game that
they're working on and it's not been
officially revealed other than Major
Nelson shout-out to the major tweeting
at someone else being like oh that game
that obsidians making pretty cool right
and then the other person going yes the
game is cool I can't wait til others
yeah like you both need to grow up what
how many papers they had to sign just to
do that I do that but yeah they are
rumored to be working on another big
game which I hope is Alpha Protocol -
he's no oh my god that would be Wow
I
for it yes I McCain that's a that game
had a lot of cool ideas that was not
executed great but yeah I like to see
you miss a second chance all right what
about Warner Bros Batman but I'll see
Batman game beatty's like eight months
ago oh my god Batman game well I I would
say they'd probably be a game from
Montreal and that'd probably be a game
from Rocksteady because their timelines
kind of on now aligning for that I
imagine there would be a travelers tales
Lego game there's a Star Wars one right
yet that like open world star everyone
yeah and then I don't know maybe this is
too many but like that Harry Potter game
the kids of kids use of power yeah
what about like injustice or something
from I think when was last Mortal Kombat
game I think do an injustice but I think
the plan was to support for support MK
11 for longer okay um that might mean
they skip a year but I definitely think
there will be another injustice because
that series just those two well and it's
like a whenever they relation you want
and let's DC fire up a new comic kind of
because they're the comics tied to that
franchise are always doing super well
and they're always putting big talent
behind it the comic series that ties
into just injustice is actually very
very good so I imagine they want more of
that going forward Ubisoft smaller so of
course oh yeah undoubtedly new splinter
cell game when yeah let's gonna say when
his watch dark supposed to come out
what's mine originally bike march never
joke like this was called March got
delayed till it has a new day well they
recently talked about they will delay I
think they said they will delay it
further if or they're they're willing to
delay some games if the consoles shift
which is like yeah obviously you're not
going to release a game into a console I
can't play exist right
but yeah I'm softer we're doin AC we are
yeah
watchdogs probably I don't think they'd
have fork right in there as well right
now I think AC and watchdogs are
probably the ones that they have side by
side and then they have was that roller
derby game called yeah
rocket League roller derby they have
that coming and then I don't know I kind
of I wouldn't put it past them to marry
a rabid sequel hmm I feel like that did
well enough that they would be like
let's do again yeah and then probably
one of their weird like RTS games that
no one thinks about oh I know I mean
yeah but I feel like in the past
Ubisoft they're they're always the ones
who hit like console watches really hard
like they always have all their games
are always on like next gen stuff so I
feel like yeah I'll probably just hit
the big the big stuff like tam said just
ants and whatnot how many more years do
you think they'll keep releasing just
ants on we till no one buys it anymore
till nursing homes stop existing okay
Nintendo I don't know if they will but
I'd like to hear something about
Bayonetta 3 yeah that's the wild 2 for
sure
Metroid Prime for I hope so
now is it and I don't know if they would
dedicate III to this but I want to hear
more about potential like re-releases on
switch like Metroid Prime trilogy
remaster or whatever well those that
room oh so of all the Mario games coming
to hell
yeah yeah oh yeah there is a recent
thing I think too about that like like
yeah yeah they were gonna put out that
make you something 64 and a sunshine and
that kind of business
IRA sunshine it's not good I tried
replaying it a couple years ago I I
admittedly did stop it hit a point or I
was like yeah I don't want to play
anymore so maybe that is a sign that
it's but what I did player I didn't
enjoy it what again Oh what was I saying
oh the pokemon dlc sometimes they do
stuff for games that are coming out a
little bit sooner like they had a fire
I'm gonna have a three an e3 present and
the crown Tundra expansion for a sword
and shield isn't coming out until winter
ish so did they say whoever they're done
no if I remember now
I think they've released all of the like
stuff you could get from the expansion
pass right I don't know if they're doing
another I don't know I feel like they
could do a bit more with fire him but
like a big expansion I could see that or
I could see them doing another fireman
game because I know it's pretty soon but
like that engine they they've built that
engine they've already made mmm three
houses and I feel like on des farm games
come out semi-regularly maybe ish no I
guess not that regularly but I don't
know I I could see I would be surprised
either way or they could doing your
rerelease of awakening on switch that'd
be pretty cool I wouldn't have run into
that you know people would hear that
everyone
I would buy that and I I already own it
on a perfectly functioning through yes
I've yeah I bought my 3ds with me to
this country just because of school fire
emblem money yeah I I left my 3ds at my
apartment unfortunately hate see it yep
all right last one square
you know I what's that one platinum game
that they announced last e3 or whatever
that was supposed to come out oh I
forget what it was called I know the
only reason I remember is because
Michael still talks about it whenever he
can even though they've shown like
nothing except for a trailer yeah I
think Avengers will be their big game
yeah oh yeah and they'll have that near
replicant remake I imagine yeah they
announced recently I bet you there will
be another big near game fairly soon I
mean maybe this is it but I feel like
they're gonna try and do a full-on new
entry in the near franchise because near
as popular now what a world we live in
Tomb Raider it's been a while since
shadow the Tomb Raider right give it a
break yeah I think they're done with
that for a bit which is a shame mmm
because I'd be far more interested in
personally I'm more interested in more
Tomb Raider than I would be for this
Avengers game wow I'm sorry I just did
does not interest me at all the second
it was like oh this is kind of like a
destiny thing huh I was like I don't I
don't know why save my thoughts on that
yeah it has its own distinct apparently
it has its own distinct campaign with
the story and it's caught Miss Marvel in
it and I love Miss Marvel so I'm willing
to give over sorry yeah I'll give it a
shot I hope it's great but okay let's
just say I wouldn't be as excited yeah
some souls back into superhero eyes
though because you all right any any
last-minute predictions you might have
in any of these that you want to throw
out there before we move on did we talk
about Microsoft or yeah did it first
sorry DD that I I can't be more
enthusiastic it's also April so I'm just
like no teasing
we PlayStation we have an on PlayStation
I think PlayStation was left out just
because they're not at e3 normally or at
least they haven't been but we can talk
about some PlayStation predictions
quickly but going to right I have a
feeling that might talk about the
PlayStation 2 5
I hope so
it's so weird cuz was it didn't I don't
think it was like someone was saying
that the like their D originally had
like a grander plan for revealing like
the controller and then they just did
like a weird blog post about it because
it was a Bloomberg report that mentioned
that their plans have been based carpet
because of what's happening and based on
that there is kind of like some
indication that just noticed during the
history that earlier but yeah I think
because of that there's some
implications that there are going to be
more announcements I think at the very
least I'll have something because we
need to know more about horizon coming
to PC and that kind of stuff because the
Hermon host oblivious resin wasn't your
home and house mentioned that and off
the back of that I I'm pretty sure that
I'm convinced that the reason they're
doing that is to drum up interest in a
second horizon game it would be foolish
of them not to put another one of those
games and having it timed so it's like
an early slash launch PlayStation 5 ty
all seems just like the smartest and the
best way to get that console off to a
good start
on a strong luck footing so imagine
we'll see that they still need to re
message some stuff around the last of us
just to assuage fears and give people a
reminder that it's a game that's coming
out so I think they'll do that as well
they'll probably they're definitely
going to show off the console itself
soon I imagine like Sony is a little
more inclined to get involved with
whatever III has become now just because
not III anymore the Sony kind of part of
it them backing away from it was a
little to do with like behind the scenes
ESA stuff as well
and now that ESA is basically falling
apart and III doesn't really exist i and
the timing necessitates I reckon they'll
be around whatever the e3 style
shenanigans that happen are so I think
we'll see you PlayStation soon
horizon - you know what are the odds
that horizon - is a PS 5 launch title or
something I don't know about that feels
do well early does it because I think I
think isin one came out in 2016
yeah I think it will be I'm not saying
that because I know things just got
feeling I think at least launch window
and like I feel like a horizon game
would be perfect for a launch of new
console cuz I mean knowing guerrilla
games they're gonna make that make it
look as beautiful as possible they want
to put something really shiny and
polished on that new console the only
thing that the only reason I'd question
is because the original horizon horizon
zero dawn was very ambitious and I feel
like a lot of launch titles tend to be
scaled back a little bit in order to hit
that release date so that's why maybe
launch Windows seems a little more
reasonable for me but I think I think
there will also be like a concerted
effort to do like a almost packaged up
PlayStation 4 games that are
high-profile and present them as like
best on PlayStation 5 or like improved
for PlayStation file even if it's like
small updates like def stranding loading
times you know what Bourne what extras
yeah yeah on 60 frames per second and
then you know you know various other
spider-man is now has got you know I
take demo we showed everyone about the
city loading in fast you can play it
yourself and then there's our four other
few things on the side that have a lot
of potential Blue Point is supposedly
making a new game holding on holding our
hope it's a Demon Souls remake but that
studio I think has been
biding its time to make something of its
own so I wouldn't be surprised if they
announced like a remake and/or their own
new IP yeah because they said they
they're doing a big a big remake as well
right yeah yeah I also feel like they've
been building up to like hey we can make
our own games too you know I'm a real
boy I'd love for them to do that
awesome yeah and they've certainly
earned it I'd love it if the game was
just like a stitch together of different
parts from all the games they've remade
the Metal Gear Solid Snake and his job
is to defeat the colossi and and watch
out for Titans falling yeah yeah that's
it
John Luke do you wanna read this last
question yes it's a bit long high after
dark crew I hope you all are keeping
well you all have gotten numerous
questions about how to become a writer
for GameSpot I would like to know what
it takes to become part of the video
team and what you all look for in
potential interns or hires I've been in
university for film editing and I'm
about to graduate I'm scared shitless
like most kids graduating right now are
sorry for the dangling participle
participle don't worry about nobody
cares about those I recently made an
analysis style video for my games a
narrative class on dune 2016 it's not
great but I had a lot of fun working on
it and now I'm working on a video for a
game called refund I just finished my
senior thesis film but I just want to
work with gains footage what do you look
for in someone who wants to join the
team as an editor who also definitely
works in other areas as well everyone
says this and I won't be the last but
what would be a dream come true
oh but it would be a dream come true to
work with you to work for you Oh
y'all are the best thanks for doing the
podcast even with all this [ __ ] it's a
real treat to have you now and shout out
to my top three favorite people Tam
Michael and Callie you know the real
ones all right well I don't what's
happening well I refuse to answer this
question
John Lucio one of my favorite people as
are you Jake thank you thank you yeah so
we've had similar questions before about
writing as he mentions oh did I not say
Adam sorry Oh from Adam we've had
similar questions before about writing
and then we've had someone who's asked
this question but Danny was on John Luke
wasn't on and I talked a little bit
about it so I kind of want to get John
Luke's take on it uh yeah I mean I would
say like the big thing I always think
about is is sort of just your your
willingness to put yourself out there
and and just make stuff like I mean it
can be it can absolutely be like really
difficult to make stuff on the side if
you know you have a full-time job and
you work in school but I would really
say like finding that time to make
videos even if they're not good like it
doesn't matter like what matters is that
you're you're putting an effort and
you're improving and you're learning you
know I started a YouTube channel with my
buddies we you know we're like streaming
on Twitch we did like a live show we did
on canned stuff we basically just were
like we'll do everything we will do as
much as possible and I think as you do
that you kind of like develop your you
not only develop your skills but I think
you kind of like start to figure out
what what you're good at and like then
you start honing those skills yeah which
I would just say it's really all about
just putting yourself out there blurt
learn I mean for me like the the thing
that got me this job was that I knew how
to use a TriCaster which is a edit like
a live broadcasting software not to say
that I didn't have other skills but that
was kind of like the big thing on my
portfolio that kind of gave me a I guess
an advantage over other people so learn
just learn as many skills as possible
learn unique skills give yourself
something give basically
put something on your resume that like
makes you valuable above another person
because I think if I was just somebody
who edited videos on YouTube like I I
wouldn't have stood out as much as other
people and I think it's because I like
put in that extra effort to like learn a
more niche software like like like the
TriCaster that that gave me an advantage
yeah whatever you do make sure you learn
on a camera that doesn't overheat
internal camera is actually very nice
sony a7 3 and like I I got to defend it
because whenever it dies on stream or
something like that people like tell us
never to buy that let us know what
camera that is we never buying them like
there's actually a phenomenal camera the
issue is that it's not meant to be on
for long periods of time mm-hmm
but anyway yeah I mean pretty much what
John Luke said I think the biggest thing
is figure out what you want to do and
keep at it
like a youtube channel is a good place
to start just because everyone's very
familiar with YouTube you can make
videos post them regularly and then it's
easy to share with with potential hirers
employers employers just add that in
general you know nobody starts out doing
like the like no idea starts out like
the coolest best idea so like being able
to workshop an idea I think on our video
team being creative and coming up with
creative ways to cover video games
specifically for the video format is
really important but sometimes and we've
all had to do this sometimes you just
have to do you know the basic
plug-and-play story or the basic plug
and play video and show that you can do
the simple things really really well so
that's another thing I would say for
anybody who wants to get into the
industry is make sure you can do the
basics super super well because you
never be able to go beyond those things
if you can't cut a video together
basically properly or put a sentence
together properly sort of also adjacent
to that is is like don't worry too much
about like how much like the quality of
the tech you have like I think it's
really easy to fall down a trap of like
well I have to have a really high
quality camera I have to have like a
really good microphone I have to get
like the best capture card like that
that doesn't matter at the beginning
because I think you can fall into that
trap and then you can feel like well I
just need to wait until I get like the
right equipment to make stuff like you
can make stuff on like a webcam you can
make stuff on your phone you can make
stuff just with like a basic mic like I
just start making stuff with what you
have and then go from there
like I used to I used to record videos
video game footage off of like oh my god
I don't even basically it was like a I
would plug the console directly into
this like device that would record DVDs
and so I had to like and then it would
it would record on a small window in the
device because my dad just happened to
have this and so I would like sit there
like hunched over with this like tiny
little box and I would like play games
like that just so that I could capture
footage because I didn't have because
this was like before commercial capture
cards were a thing and like that is and
then I would like take the DVD and I
would like put it in my computer and
like offload the footage and that's how
I would record game footage so just like
find what you have and just get out
there and make it like I definitely do
not stress like having the the best
equipment like I I used to be like that
where I would fall into that trap and it
just prevents you from making stuff yeah
John Luke's point - I feel like one of
the things that a lot of people don't
really think about when they want to
make videos about games or whatever it
might be is they don't really think
about voice over and like I personally
like I am way more interested in a video
if the person sounds excited and their
voice over is good as opposed to someone
who's got a really nice setup doing
voice over but it sounds flat voice over
something that's very hard to do and
it's something that you can't just watch
a video on and learn it's something you
have to practice a lot and it's
something that I still
after five years of doing it I don't
think I'm that good at and I have been
trying so hard to get better and better
at so it's one of those things that like
like with voiceover especially don't
wait until you have good equipment just
start doing it now because good vo can
take you so much further than nice
equipment I was gonna say like practice
view as much as you can like don't like
I think I struggle with it a lot because
I only started doing vo when it was
necessary as unlike I never considered
vo as the thing that I wouldn't need to
do ever because I was always trying to
be a writer and now the times when I do
vo or used to be the times where I do vo
is like oh you need to vo your feature
or vo this review that you wrote and
then as I've started to like do more of
it now I just do it for fun and practice
like without recording just so I can get
used to everything in that way I'm still
very bad at it but it's it's a work in
progress I've been doing vo since the
beginning of my career so like I never
want to go back and listen they listen
to those early video reviews I did it
because like I you know it's it's
something that you just like it's so
hard to just be like naturally good at
it really does take a lot of practice
and I also still feel like I'm very good
at it you can watch our videos by like a
lot of the people that do it on our team
are super good like so if you need some
kind of like examples just watch watch a
lot of those videos that we make alright
I will say nothing is something that I
love about GameSpot that you don't get
it every at every outlet is we have a
lot of peer editing and that it extends
from editorial to video and I thought of
this because we do have people who are
helping us with our vo like if I if
tomorrow or I normally were in the
office if we go in to the vo booth John
Luger Jake are another video producer is
gonna be in there with us who catching
our mistakes asking us to retake lines
so enlisting the help of a friend to
just go over your work with you can be
a really helpful process in my
experience like peer editing has been
one of my favorite things about working
at GameSpot because you just learn
something from being the editor and from
being the the receiver of that
constructive criticism so like having
somebody check out your reel or having
somebody like hey how's like hey I did
like a minute of voiceover like do I
sound weird like do I sound natural you
know just have somebody that you trust
to give you that feedback because I
think that's something people really
struggle with when they're starting out
is not really having anyone to give to
get feedback from yeah and if you if you
do want to share your work somewhere and
you want feedback I I'm plugging it
again you should join the GameSpot
discord surveys you've got a little
promo channel where people have been
sharing videos they've made streams they
do and a lot of us have gone through and
checked out a lot of those videos and
whatnot so I shameless plug but join the
games about discourse every speaking of
shameless plugs though where can we find
you guys on twitter cali doing a start
you can find me on twitter at doji co i
NK yd o ji k ko i haven't been tweeting
a lot because time isn't real and i
forget about tweeting but i post a lot
of like our animal crossing content as
we do it I'm really excited because John
we've made a handy infographic for our
Animal Crossing fish guide said I am
obsessed with I think he did such a good
job
oh thank you to help you identify the
size of a fish and so by the time this
podcast is up our fish guide will have
like a special new upgrade so that's
what kind of stuff you will find from me
on Twitter right now maybe a cool screen
shot or two from my game how are you
John Luke oh you can find me at channel
excite be my big thing I going up is the
resonable thing I mentioned earlier it's
gonna be I replayed the game and I kind
of dived into a couple of the big things
that I would like to see them to do with
that game if they if they do in fact we
make it at some point and yes look
forward to that and more I'm on to a to
more H I'll plug a bunch of things
nothing really of my own
and it's just a bunch of things that
we're making we have a we now have a
daily news show them here's on Gamescom
and also on youtube you can find it on
this very channel if you're watching the
video version it's called safe state
daily news roundup hosted by a bunch of
people from GameSpot think the first
episodes from Lucy's second episodes
from chastity but you can probably
expect to see some other familiar faces
those will be daily probably end of the
day PT but we can make it so that their
content is relevant and it's just a
quick way to catch up on what's happened
in the day and then we have good news
gaming which is a show that Lucy
launched which is kind of like the fun
stuff that happens on Fridays there's a
new episode of true fiction out that
Kurt did which is got all about Fargo
and it's amazing so yeah check that
stuff out pretty much it cool and then
you can find me at jacob deck and like I
said my fallout video should be up now
so if you're curious about giving
fallout another shot you can check that
video out other than that I'm cutting
some video reviews that are coming up
soon
so be on the lookout for that if you're
curious about well yours tactics already
talked about and then another game which
were re reviewing which should be a fun
one anyway that's it that's GameSpot
after dark episode 38 thank you so much
for tuning in and we'll see you next
week my
[Music]